c'est vraiment une invasion qui du coup
est vraiment redessinée par rapport à ce
qu'on avait vu au début n'hésitez pas à
réagir sur sur nos différents canaux sur
le figaro sur le figaro live sur youtube
vous vous abonnez vous nous posez toutes
vos questions on y répond je voudrais
qu'on parle de kiev de kiev d'abord du
nord comment ça se passe à kiev alexis
les russes ne sont plus du tout là ils
ne sont plus du tout là en fait ils se
sont retirés alors on a très envie quand
on voit ça c'est les cartes sont
frappantes en fait les cartes là toute
la zone bleue c'est l'émeute est
reconquise par par les ukrainiens par
rapport à l'avancé maximale des rues
donc on voit que les russes à un moment
était quand même aux portes de kiev
notamment par l'ouest mais aussi par
l'est en fait il est trois fronts enfin
trois percées russe qui a lancé avec
kiev et les russes étaient vraiment au
port de la capitale simplement il dit
ils n'ont plus réussi à avancer pour là
on s'en rend pas compte forcément sur la
carte mais kiev saint jean qui est
gigantesque 2002 8 millions d'habitants
est en fait les russes pour rennes pour
encercler kiev aurait dû tenir une zone
circulaire n'a périmètre de 150 km c'est
absolument énorme et donc ils n'ont ils
n'ont pas réussi chaque jour il avancé -
il ya notamment les localités de butch à
dire pin de gosses thomas qui sont
désormais célèbre est connu pour demain
de tristes eu raison alors on va
reparler janka a aussi gelé bourdieu cas
voilà mais si vous voulez les russes ne
pouvait pas y arriver on va revenir
pourquoi ils pouvaient pas rêver mais
donc là ils ont fait un choix
stratégique de se retirer complètement
du son du nord pour se re basculer leurs
forces vers l'est et alors ça ressemble
énormément une défaite alors on peut pas
parler de défaite militaire parce qu'en
fait il n'y a pas eu de combats où ils
ont été défaits ils ont décidé de se
retirer mais malgré tout c'est une
défaite heureuse parce que ce qu'on voit
par là c'est que l'objectif
russe qui était de prendre kiev pas
forcément pour conquérir l'intégralité
de l'ukraine et la tenir ensuite pendant
pendant des années mais en tout cas pour
faire tomber le gouvernement et bien cet
objectif russe il n'a pas été il n'a pas
été atteint alors régner un putin nous
l'avait jamais présenté comme tel nom
qu'il peut toujours dire je l'avais
mehmedi mais malgré tout c'est le
colonel michel goya
qui expliqué qu'ils avaient pas
tellement de doutes en fait les halles
et rue sont
déployés en ukraine vite armée d'accord
est armé donc à peu près 150 mille
hommes au total et bien sûr ces huit
armées il y en avait cinq étaient sur le
front du nord
donc l'objectif initial de kiev 2-2 des
russes il n'y a pas de doute c'était le
fond d'une heure c'était kiev
aujourd'hui ils ont complètement
rebasculer vers laisse donc il ya bien
une redéfinition des objectifs de guerre
de la russie alors vous voyez cette
carte en bleu en haut ce matin dans la
région de soumis on le voit c'est le
nord-est le nord-est en bleu est bien le
gouverneur annoncé que la zone était
totalement libéré mais pas sûr pas
certaines parce qu'il ya encore des
opérations de déminage les russes se
retire qu'on est dans l'hérault se sont
retirés
on le hall on était quasiment sûre
depuis depuis plusieurs jours en fait ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est qu'il
ya donc kiev le long du donbass à peu
près on va dire le long du n'y a pas on
le note qu'elle gonfle d'ukrainiens
qu'on voit ici à 150 km de la frontière
biélorusse les russes ont avancé depuis
la biélorussie vers ghafli ici voilà
sans descendu comme ceux-ci verglacées
et des deux côtés du nieppe à l'ouest
par la centrale de tchernobyl nord et à
l'est d'une ligne être de ce côté là là
leur mobile et à l'est il ya une il y
avait une ville qui s'appelle cherniff
la cantine d'une grosse ville et donc
leur percée vers kiev était compliquée
parce qu'il fallait qu'ils ont ce qui
passe à côté de czerny fils ont pas
réussi à prendre la ville et puis par
l'est on voit très bien si cette percée
c'était la grande percée par le
territoire soumis ce serait de soumis en
fait un accord juste pas loin de là pas
si loin de la frontière russe même très
proche vous avez une grande ville qui
s'appelle soumis et donc les ressources
des parents ont essayé d'avancer très
vite vers kiev donc ils ont contourné
soumis après ils ont essayé de
l'encercler mais si vous voulez tout ça
c'était quand même dans l'objectif de
prendre kiev et surtout ce qu'on voit là
c'est qu'en fait les russes étaient
engagés dans une manoeuvre
d'encerclement d'un très grand nombre de
villes ukrainiennes et de grandes villes
ukrainiennes on n'a pas parlé de kiev on
a parlé de czerny fonds a parlé de
soumis juste en dessous vous avez la
deuxième grande ville d'ukraine qui et
kharkiv c'est un million et demi
d'habitants et donne toujours cet
exemple parce qu'il est frappant les
russes ont fait deux guerres en
tchétchénie l'ensemble de la tchétchénie
c'est 1,5 million d'habitants celle que
la guerre de tchétchénie c'est juste
l'équivalent de la bataille de kharkiv
est donc là les re se sont dit on ne
peut pas tenir autant de sièges on va
sans agrafes on ne va pas y arriver et
donc on voit encore une fois cette
configuration vraiment au niveau
stratégique de la russie mais ça veut
dire que l'opération l'acte 1 de
l'opération militaire spéciale comme
comme les russes disent en ukraine a
échoué ça c'est très clair j'ai encore
une question sur ce retrait des des
russes alors d'accord il se retire puis
se réorganise on n'a pas un
on saisit pas toujours si magique rien
dit c'est une défaite les russes disent
que c'est une réorganisation cette fois
que les deux peuples et de la paix que
les deux alors on a été fait pour l'acte
1 1 et par dios et une réorganisation et
un redéploiement ont vu l'acte ii vers
le dombass et on va en parler mais il se
retire comme les seins si j'ose dire on
a vu arriver les images de boudhha la
semaine dernière de borodianka des mines
c'est une stratégie de la terreur on
part mais on laisse des traces en fait
ce qui est intéressant c'est que dès le
début dès le 24 février très rapidement
d'ailleurs des enquêtes ont été lancées
notamment par le royaume uni auprès de
la cpi parce qu'il il y aurait eu des
crimes de guerre dès le départ mais on
parle et de quoi ce moment là on parlait
notamment de bombardements indiscriminés
des populations civiles de l' usage dans
les villes de deux bombes à
sous-munitions une bombe à
sous-munitions c'est assez simple c'est
une bombe principal et puis quand elle
arrive au dessus de sa cible elle
déploie un chapelet de petites bombes
pour faire plein de dégâts sur une
grande surface est donc très rapidement
on a compris qu'il y avait des crimes de
guerre
qui j'ai envie de dire malheureusement
sont relativement classique dans ce
genre de guerre il ya d'ailleurs aussi
quelques soient les armées ou classique
pour les russes là dessus a donné là je
parle des premiers crimes de guerre où
l'on pensait et d'ailleurs ce genre de
crimes de guerre ont été aussi relevé du
côté ukrainien hier on a encore vu que
des des soldats ukrainien
quasiment de manière certaine achevé des
soldats russes au sol mais si vous
voulez abuja il faut bien comprendre
qu'on a on est monté d'un cran
en termes de en terme de gravité des
faits ce qu'on a vu tout simplement
c'est un massacre de populations civiles
et on parle pas de quelques personnes on
parle de centaines de personnes les
images sont absolument frappante il ya
des des civils qui ont été tués d'une
balle dans la tête alors qu'ils avaient
les mains liées derrière le dos
c'est tout ça plus loin il ya pas de
mots c'est de la sauvagerie c'est
évidemment contraire à toutes les lois
de la guerre et c'est même contraire à
toute morale voilà donc là c'est un fait
et donc du coup c'est des crimes de
guerre
reste ensuite à prouver déjà les
terrifier les gens qui en sont à des
enquêtes et ensuite à dire ce sont bien
les russies ensuite à surtout à
déterminer quel est le niveau de
responsabilité est-ce que c'est d'aider
des soldats qui ont fait ça isolément
est-ce que c'est au niveau d'un
commandement on parle beaucoup d'un
lieutenant colonel russe qu'à la tête
d'une unité dans la zone de bouchain
qui est très très visiblement est
responsable voilà mais ensuite est-ce
que ça remonte au dessus est-ce que ça
fait partie d'une stratégie
militaire c'est aussi l'enjeu de toutes
ces enquêtes qui vont avoir lieu
malheureusement jamais dire dans les
prochaines années c'est des enquêtes qui
n'équipe m très longtemps à aboutir et
si vous voulez selon la responsabilité
qui sera établi on peut franchement
aujourd'hui se poser la question de
est-ce que en plus d'être des crimes de
guerre il n'y a pas là des crimes contre
les mines contre l'humanité
alors un point parce que le président
est lenski parle de génocide pour
l'instant il fallait l'intérieur ancien
greer si vous pouvez nous expliquer nos
différences crimes de guerre crimes
contre l'humanité génocides rapidement
pour ce soit car globale ce qui peut
rien lorsque sam pas simple pour
présider peut-être un peu trop
schématique mais les crimes de guerre
c'est tous les actes qui sont commis
dans le cadre de conflits armés et qui
ne répondent pas aux lois de la guerre
c'est un bombardement comme je l'aï fait
contre des populations civiles
c'est des soldats qui sont tués alors
qu'ils se sont rendus enfin voilà c'est
ce genre de choses là un crime contre
l'humanité c'est beaucoup plus grave
c'est quand justement il ya un massacre
systématique
planifié de population civile il faut
que la responsabilité montrent assez
haut et que ça soit assez massif est par
ailleurs un crime 2 contre l'humanité
peut par ailleurs être un crime de
guerre c'est l'un et l'autre sont pas
exclusifs un crime de guerre enfin voilà
et par ailleurs il ya une troisième
catégorie most hid le génocide ou là il
faut prouver une volonté politique
grosso modo dan il est
un groupe humain au sens très large a
peut être un groupe religieux un groupe
culturel un groupe national
et là il faut prouver notamment natation
l'intentionnalité
de 2 ce crime et c'est ce qui fait que
pour l'instant les juristes sont quand
même d'accord pour dire qu'on ne peut
pas parler encore de génocide en ukraine
peut-être ne le pourra pas mais en
revanche génocide ça a un impact c'est
un symbole politique et c'est pour ça
que les ukrainiens l'emploi juste
peut-être pour terminer sur cette
question parce que j'ai une question
juste derrière abuja je joue là relais
c'est jésus en personne qui nous pose la
question sur youtube vous vous abonnez
vous nous posez des questions concernant
les crimes de guerre qu'en est-il de
boudhha tout n'est pas clair on donne
pas toujours les mêmes dates c'est ce
qu'il dit on parle de début avril à fin
mars ce que tout le monde est en
sécurité pour l'instant c'est pas
forcément très clair le récemment fait
ce qu'il semblait haute ou des bars au
tout départ on s'était dit ces crimes
ont été commis à partir du moment les
russes se sont retirés de butch à ses
dires finalement dans les derniers jours
et là on se rend compte que ces crimes
ont été commis probablement pendant
plusieurs semaines ya des photos s'était
dit quand il montrait pas leur taille
notamment qu'il qui le montrent donc
voilà c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'assez massif pour revenir sur l'aspect
juridique
s'est créé mais là c'est auprès la cour
pénale internationale que ça se joue
sauf que la russie n'est pas signataire
de rome qui est quel est le statut de
rome qui est qu'est-ce qui organise la
cour pénale internationale et donc si
vous voulez on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
condamné directement
la russie est jugé bon d'ailleurs
rapidement venir poutine pour ça il
faudrait grosso modo
que venien poutine à jour quitte
quittent le territoire russe et qu'ils
soient dans un autre pays puis extradé
ou freinent la série ce qui est arrivé
avec d'autres chefs d'état mais si vous
voulez il ya un problème juridique c'est
que par ailleurs même si les faits sont
qualifiés que des responsables sont sont
prouvés et identifié éprouvées comme tel
et bien c'est pas pour autant que les
responsables russes
leur peine sera prononcée exécuté voilà
donc on parlait encore une fois ce sont
des enquêtes qui peuvent mettre des
années donc c'est un processus très long
et en parallèle de ce processus
judiciaire il ya le processus politique
qu'on a vu l'émotion une en seconde
partie du comité international
l'exclusion de la russie du conseil des
droits de l'homme de l'onu et que
vous vouliez qu'on parle du dombass et
c'est normal parce que c'est là que tout
risque de se passer joue je vous ramène
à ce papier les russes lancent la
bataille du dombass est paru ce matin
dans dans le figaro avec ces mots
l'armée russe va tenter une manoeuvre
classique prendre en tenaille les
troupes ukrainienne défendant le dombass
veux vous montrer la carte et vous allez
nous expliquer ensuite avec vous allez
nous nous expliquer tout ça alexis pour
savoir comment comment ça se passe cette
carte elle est ici là voilà on est à
l'est du pays la zone en rouge expliquez
nous alors en fait ce qu'il ya de
l'effort on peut repartir depuis le
début quand même donc 2014 la révulsion
du maiden etc les soulèvements dans la
région du dombass et si voilà les russes
interviennent même s'ils disent qu'ils
n'interviennent pas et finalement
apparaît deux républiques séparatistes
de deux nièces et l'ouganda le dombass
est une grande région minière de l'est
de l'ukraine qui est plutôt russophone à
dire plutôt risso fidh et russes le fils
à venir qu'on souhaite faire partie de
la russie bien sûr bien sûr
les deux zones en rouge plus foncée là
vous me confirmer ses talents music
c'est par là puisque ça c'est les
reliques séparatisme et faut bien
comprendre qu'ils sont aux mains des
séparatistes depuis plusieurs années
depuis depuis 2014 a simplement les
séparatistes en 2014 n'ont pas réussi à
prendre l'intégralité du dombass en
tongs région historique et notamment ils
n'ont pas pris en 2014 l'intégralité des
2 oblast des deux régions de john yates
est lougansk est donc un objectif qui
d'ailleurs est affirmé par les
séparatistes et par les russes c'est que
c'est de reprendre l'intégralité de ces
deux hommes-là lors ces deux au blad est
ce qu'elle est mais que cette zone en
blanc ici assez le dombass qui n'a pas
été pris par les rues selon les sources
à l'époque je ne sais pas si on voit
mais c'est le très noir
ici voilà celui là c'est l'humain ça
tout ça c'est les deux oblath de donner
accès lougansk est donc grosso modo les
séparatistes depuis 2014 contrôle 40% de
deux nièces ici la zone voilà orange
france le contrôle et 40% de lougansk
est d'ores et déjà depuis le 24 février
ils ont avancé donc désormais contrôle
90% de lougansk et 40
5% de montgros la suite d'un corner et
donc ce qui reste à prendre c'est
laisser la poche blanche qu'on voit avec
notamment cramatte ans qui dans cette
ville alors cette ville où d'ailleurs ce
matin on a appris qu'il y avait eu des
bombardements au crématoire ce qui est
visible des dizaines de civils qui sont
morts dans la gare de cramât torse c'est
depuis 2014 la capitale
provinciale du donia de du donia puisque
deux nièces et aux mains des
séparatistes
la ville de deux nièces et donc là on
voit très bien le mouvement c'est un
mouvement de tenaille qui passe à la
fois par le nord on voit il ya beaucoup
d'hommes de komball par le pas par le
nord par l'est et par le sud aidez-nous
m l'idée c'est vraiment de quoi c'est
les ukrainiens
les russes et les allemands pour la
seconde guerre mondiale appeler ça un
chaudron
de les coincer ensuite d'accord les
ukrainiennes aurait plus qu'un seul
choix c'est soit se faire encercler
et résister le plus longtemps possible
soit se retirer avec tous les risques
d'une retraite il serait vulnérable
alors un point
on voit qu'il ya eu la ville d'izu mme
au nord qui a été ici une 13 russe
importante parce que ça matérialiser le
mouvement de tenaille par le nord une
prise russa a qu'à l'époque récemment
récemment c'était il ya un accord ce qui
est 10 jours on va dire que à partir du
moment où on a vu que les russes essayer
de prendre visiom on a compris qu'il y
avait cette manoeuvre d'encerclement
qui était en cours maintenant ce qu'il
faut quand même préciser c'est que tout
au dessus du dombass il ya le tour
stratégie de marioupol à je voulais
venir à la réole alors je lis aussi dans
le figaro de ce matin qui ont peut-être
finir soit n'a
plus sa place ça me paraît très
intéressant pour comprendre que c'est un
problème pour les russes donc alors
justement ce que je voulais dire par là
c'est qu'il faut pas croire que dans les
prochains jours les charrues devons
avancer de 30 kilomètres par jour ou 50
km par jour vont fermer la tna et que la
semaine prochaine les raisons dire on a
gagné le dombass pourquoi ça il faut
vraiment l'avant à l'esprit
les ukrainiens sont pas bêtes depuis
2014 savaient très bien qui ils étaient
eux-mêmes menacés par une parle
l'attak pro-russe et donc il était
fortifiée à cet endroit là et par
ailleurs il y a aujourd'hui les
estimations disent qu'il y à peu près
40% de l'ensemble des troupes
ukrainienne elles sont dans le donbass
donc c'est un point absolument
une classe il faut bien comprendre que
le fait qu'il n'ya plus le front d'une
heure ça veut pas dire que la guerre
d'ukraine est plus petit et justement il
faisait le tout à l'heure que les russes
les forces russes s'étaient retirés du
nain on le voit les ânes en bleu pour
peut-être revenir vers le nom basse mais
est-ce que les forces qui défendent les
farces ukrainienne qui défendent et kiev
vont aussi venir dans cette zone du
nombre évidemment évidemment et donc je
voulais
redéploiement mais des deux côtés alors
d'accord ailleurs c'est le caylar et aux
russes les russes disent maintenant à
postériori 10 kiev n'a jamais été notre
objectif stratégique
c'était juste pour fixer des troupes
ukrainienne à kiev c'est pas le cas on
fait pas une manne communication tout ça
ça c'est de la communication on n'envoie
pas de chien car mais sur 8 vers une
position qui sera leur mai mais ce qui
est certain c'est que là il va y avoir
un redéploiement ukrainien et
redéploiement russe donc la bataille du
donbass qui sera peut-être une bataille
décisive
ça sera pas une bataille de quelques
jours ça sera une bataille de plusieurs
semaines et on verra alors à peut-être
après que l'une des dates butoir pour
vladimir poutine c'est le 9 mai
exactement avait alors parlé de cette
date du 9 mai par mois alors c'est tout
simple hôtel le 9 mai 1945
c'est un grand jour dans l'histoire
russe est une grande fête avec chaque
année une immense parade militaire
à moscou sur la place rouge et c'est
tout simplement pour célébrer la
victoire de l'union soviétique sur le
nazisme il faut bien comprendre que pour
lire une symbolique très forte sur cette
date là au delà de l'ukraine c'est une
journée historique pour les russes
puisque leurs
romans récits nationale s'est énormément
construit sur non seulement la victoire
soviétique contre le nazisme mais
également sur les sacrifices que cela a
exigé j'ai il ya eu des déjeuners plus
le chiffre est exact ne veut pas dire de
bêtises mais ça se compte en millions de
soldats soviétiques morts dans les
guerres mondiales et des deux millions
de civils par ailleurs le siège de
leningrad et donc pour les russes est
absolument capital et la vue le récit
qu'ils ont fait de la gare ils craignent
qu'une sorte de dans la propagande russe
de redites puisque leur objectif c'est
d'éliminer les nazis ils sont des crèmes
c'est la version c'était le problème les
premiers mots de la demie retour pour
justifier presse que cette attaque alors
si vous voulez des données nazis on a
fait une
article dessus il y en a les liens
troubles entre azoff le bataillon azoff
il faut pas lié
par le gouvernement ukrainien pour plein
de raisons historiques on peut
comprendre etc mais en revanche ce n'est
pas le gouvernement ukrainien l'assuré
et l'ukraine n'est pas néo nazis on va
juste précisé que le président veulent
des marines qui est juif on connaît
assez peu de juifs nazis voilà donc donc
là c'est le récit de deux russes ne
tient pas mais c'est celui ci est donc
évidemment le 9900 qu'avait le 9 mai
pour les russes et une date butoir il
faudra à vladmir poutine
d'une manière ou d'une autre montrez le
9 mai le 9 mai prochain que son
opération militaire spéciale est une
réussite et lui faut le nom basse et
manu paul nous on pourrait parler
maintenant
vous pouvez évidemment nous poser vos
questions alexis et très calé vous
l'avez vu il vous répond il répond à
tous on va parler de marioupol vous
abonner 1 sur youtube pour pour proposer
vocation va parler de marioupol je vous
montre à nouveau à nouveau cette cette
carte complète de marioupol de l'ukraine
avec mario paul qui est tout en bas dans
le sud est du pays c'est une ville qui
donne sur la mer et je lis ce matin dans
le figaro l'offensive n'est pas non plus
imaginable dans le donbass estiment les
stratèges sans la chute de marioupol qui
occupe toujours des milliers de soldats
russes ou de ses supplétifs impossible
d'attaquer le reste de l'ukraine sans
avoir pris marioupol qui semble
complètement isolé alors impossible de
finir ce mouvement de tenaille moment je
le mouvement de tenay il a commencé il a
commencé depuis plusieurs semaines mais
revanche s'ils peuvent pas ce que j ai
tout à l'heure il ya 40% des troupes
ukrainienne dont le nombre s'est par
ailleurs il ya de nouvelles troupes qui
vont arriver donc ça sera probablement
plus de 40%
marioupol faut bien comprendre c'est une
vie une grande ville quatre cent mille
habitants avant la guerre ils vont
rester cent cinquante mille à peu près
actuellement c'est une ville stratégique
à plus d'un titre d'abord c'est le c'est
là où le bataillon azoff est le plus
présent c'est vraiment le là où ils ont
investi donc encore une fois dans le
récit national de vladimir poutine du
coup c'est hautement symbolique puisque
on va dire pour le faire bref si jamie
fait tomber marie-paule il peut dire que
son objectif de dénazification est
réussi et atteint
donc pascale mariot paul carril et
d'ukrainiens qui défendent marioupol ce
sont les soldats de l'armée absolument
et des soldats du bataillon azoff qui
elles ne dépendent pas de l'ukraine
enfin une nation c'est là où je veux
dire par ailleurs battre le bataillon
faisait depuis un certain nombre
d'années a été réintégré officiellement
dans l'armée d'accord mais d'un
gouvernement qu'ils existent comme tel
d'accord avec ces symboles scrutin
donc ça c'est une première chose d'une
deuxième chose c'est qu'on voit que
marioupol donne sur la mer d'azov qui
est une mer quasiment fermée pour y
entrer si vous passez vous voyez par le
le détroit de kertch qui entre la crimée
alors là où il ya le bandeau voilà la
situation
voilà et donc grosso modo si près de
marib paul
la mer d'azov devient une sorte de lacs
de l'arc de lacq revoilà donc on
comprend alors ça c'est une question que
je me pose je j'ai l'impression que
marioupol le la mer d'azov aujourd'hui
ce sont des navires russes qui la
tiennent un an c'est déjà le cas en
réalité on les ukrainiens ne pouvait
déjà plus en adoptant vais les passer
par le round 4 donc c'est peut-être pas
le plus essentiel le savez que je pense
et je me pose la question j'imagine que
tous ceux qui nous regardent se pose
cette question là l'impression que cette
guerre ne peut pas se déployer pour les
russes tant qu'ils n'ont pas pris cette
ville qui semble complètement dévastée
de marioupol c'est ça qui interroge mais
c'est un grand pas aimé ça c'est c'est
la question des buts de guerre russe il
faut jamais oublier que les buts de
guerre il ya des buts de guerre qui sont
à la tête de vladimir poutine par
définition on peut les soupçonner on
peut faire des hypothèses on n'est pas
dans la tête de lanières poutine est par
ailleurs il y aller
les buts de guerre balle et c'est aussi
la guerre qui les détermine cedex et
l'état du rapport de forces entre les
deux entre les deux belligérants et de
ce point de vue là on peut avoir un
certain nombre d'idées c'est à dire que
il ya une solution raidir minimale pour
les russes c'est en fait de tenir donc
tout le monde a sa chance et non
négociable et par ailleurs de faire se
rejoindre la crimée territorialement et
is in voilà parce que pour l'instant la
crimée à part le pont de catch allait
couper du territoire russe et donc ça
leur permettrait en fait deux d'accord
ici sur cette zone en bas à droite l'un
est à fond là bas il ya un premier impôt
mais sinon elle est la crim est coupée
et par ailleurs nous tenons à les couper
en eau parce qu'en fait elle est
alimentée en eau par l'art le dernier
bleu on parlait en fait les ukrainiens
dès 2014 vont fermer le robinet c'est
donc donc la crimée est à ses chaînes
elle est depuis des années elles étaient
asséchées chaque été nous voilà mais met
donc si ça permet de reconstituer vous
voyez ça c'est un objectif numéro un est
de reconstituer quelque chose qui est
assez cohérent territorialement c'est à
dire le la crimée que la russie ici à
l'est aurait puisse rejoindre la galerie
par toute cette zone est donc ça faisait
un bond de terre qui comprend le gambas
zaporizhya carson je comprends je
comprendrais comme la clé mais donc
salsa on peut on peut on peut envisager
que c'est un objectif du bon vin et
après mais sait on peut imaginer des
objectifs de guerre plus large et
notamment de prendre les rives de la mer
noire mais là c'est un objectif à plus
long terme long terme j'ai une question
sur eux-mêmes et sont revenus à
marioupol quand même les russes n'ont
pas fini parce qu'en fait il reste 3000
à 4000 soldats ukrainien visiblement et
c'est un terrain urbain où ils avancent
très lentement les russes les ukrainiens
connaissent mieux le terrain mais les
russes par définition et dans les
combats urbains ya un avantage à la
défense et donc les russes avancent très
lentement et on
pensait que mario poehl tomberez en
plusieurs jours il est probable qu'il
faille attendre encore plusieurs
semaines et c'est autant de force se
ruent donc des milliers de russes qui
sont concentrés pendant ce temps là à
marioupol et qui peuvent pas aller
prendre la thonaille du droit j'ai une
j'ai une question sur sur le figaro ces
phases-là qui nous demandent les
occidentaux ainsi livré un grand nombre
de drones et d'armes anti-aériennes
récemment pour aider à fixer les russes
au donbass est-ce que là aussi les aides
d'armes s'il y en a vont se concentrer
sur le banc base with toutes les armes
ukrainiennes lapin définitionnelle et
les armes qu'on fournit aux ukrainiens
vont plutôt allez donc bah ça c'est une
certitude celle ayant une des vraies
questions est-ce qu'il ya encore des
armes ukrainiennes des armes
occidentales qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
marine pool sachant que paul est
encerclée ce n'est pas facile d'y entrer
on a vu quelques photos de
deux drones qui semblait
juste arrivé dans la ville de marioupol
ce qui signifierait qu'il y aurait
encore des couloirs entre guillemets de
livraison
on sait très hypothétique on en a pas de
confirmation voilà j'ai une autre une
autre question qui est sur youtube celle
là quels sont les ont parlé du bataillon
d'azov ya un instant qu'elles sont les
proportions du bataillon azoff dans
l'armée ukrainienne on a une idée c'est
difficile assez faible c'est faible
c'est parce que le bataillon azoff c'est
un bataillon donc ces quelques milliers
d'hommes
l'armée ukrainienne
c'est ça ce qu'on entend c'est plus de
cent mille hommes en tout cas manière
certaine et aujourd'hui ça c'est
peut-être un point qu'il faut souligner
dès le début on pensait que c'était un
combat asymétrique c'est une énorme
armée russe fasse une petite armée
ukrainienne très rapidement on s'est dit
en trois jours s'est terminée à vivre
une règle il ya trois jours il ya peu de
dan ellis qu'il exagère évidemment mais
en ac et l'inter c'est une réalité
admise mais est servi aujourd'hui le
changement c'est que là on est face à un
combat symétrique et notamment pour une
raison qui est intéressante c'est que
poutine comme il n'a pas déclaré la
guerre commis dit que c'est une
opération militaire spéciale est pas une
guerre et bien en fait il n'a pas envie
d'envoyer les conscrits au fond donc
c'est juste des soldats contractuels le
choeur de l'armée russe mais qui n'est
pas infini on our nombre de force on le
voit c'est 150000 à 200000 hommes c'est
très peu pour prendre un pays de 600 mm
kilomètres carrés qui est plus grand que
la fonte de 40 millions d'habitants or
on fasse les ukrainiens eux ils ont
sonné le tocsin ils ont sonné la
mobilisation générale et donc ils ont
des réserves d'hommes tués sont pas des
artistes à la base à la base est lui
même à la base là l'armé nucléaire n'est
pas petit non plus donc là conflit
aujourd'hui symétrique on va parler du
sud dans un instant cette zone mais j'ai
une question quand même
comment les russes ont pu avancer si
vite au début on a l'impression très
rapidement ils sont ils ont pris
notamment de tchernobyl et ses banquiers
proches de la frontière ils sont arrivés
assez vite vers kiev et en quelques
jours et ensuite ils ont été bloqués
pendant presque un mois moine ni comment
c'est possible pour une raison très
simple avancée sur une route ce n'est
pas avancer dans une ville en fête les
russes ont fait un truc classique ma
stratégie militaire russes s'appellent
les opérations militaires en profondeur
qu'est ce que c'est c'est en fait vous
avez au début on parlait du terme
blitzkrieg parce que c'est un long nez
ça y est tu dans les différents expliqué
en fait la blitzkrieg c1
concept allemand qu'on connaît venir en
france puisqu'on a vécu et en fait c'est
une avancée principal très rapide et on
enfonce le front et puis on
est là c'est pas ça c'est vrai quand on
n'est pas spécialiste des stratégies
militaires ont dit c'est ce qu'ont voulu
faire les russes papa tout parce que
c'est pas la stratégie militaire russe
traditionnelle après il ya des
subtilités on va pas en traînant mais
globalement cette notion d' opération de
la profondeur cessé d'attaquer sur
plusieurs fronts à la fois en profondeur
c'est à dire derrière vraiment en
profondeur derrière les lignes ennemies
est complètement désorganisée la
structure des dispositifs militaires
adverse et pour qu'ils s'effondrent en
fait pour qu'il soit désorganisée et
donc c'est ce qu'on a vu non tous les
fronts les russes ont avancé très vite
ont contourné les villes ont pris les
grands axes routiers les grands noeuds
de communication mais ça va on va assez
vite par ailleurs au nord-ouest le prêt
de tchernobyl ce que vous mentionnez
tout à l'heure il ya ici il ya quasiment
personne c'est rennes le peuple et
cherniff le blaze de cheerleaders région
extrêmement peuplée soumis soumis est
une grande ville mais l'aube là c'était
très peuplées ils ont contourné soumis
c'est pour ça qu'on voit ils sont
contents et soumis et voilà ces zones là
avec ses employés ce sont des routes ou
qui contredit n'est pas vraiment le
territoire est ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le dombass est très très
peuplées en revanche deux nièces avec la
ville il ya beaucoup de vitesse a manqué
beaucoup de points à prendre et
lentement d'accord c'est 4 millions
d'habitants dounia l'ensemble de la
place c'est le blast le plus peuplé
d'ukraine est en fait le sud que vous
voyez là vraiment le sud est une région
qui n'est pas la plus densément peuplées
ducret est donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
pu avril très rapidement voilà est par
ailleurs en revanche le sud où là pour
le coup on pouvait penser que les russes
voulaient s'y installer durablement en
revanche là ils ont pris les villes donc
ils ont rapidement pris personne ils ont
après une non primés litho paul berdyev
etc
sauf qu'ensuite il veut contrôler les
villes et que l'opération du sud dès le
départ n'était pas le front principal de
la deûle a aussi aidé on va être plus
longue avance dire évidemment n'a pu
tourner pour continuer à avancer alors
justement le sud et ils ont pu annoncer
rapidement parce qu'ils avaient peu de
trot pénale paraît donc d'accord c'était
pas ici que concentré que se
concentraient les ans la digue vous nous
avait expliqué que les forces étaient
plutôt autour de kiev et dans le grand
bassin on va parler du sud g j'ai une
réaction de valve pas eu 34 / / le
figaro qui nous dit poutine pensait que
les ukrainiens étaient incapables brossé
rare il a péché par orgueil poutine
complètement j'en parlais hier avec un
très bon spécial de la russie appelle
jean de gliniasty qu annoncé
l'ambassadeur français à moscou et qui
disait il ya quelque chose de culturel
c'est dire que toujours dans la vision
grand russe bah justement il ya les
grands russes et les ukrainiens les rues
si les appelle les petits russes parce
qu'avant on appelait ça la malle russie
à la petite en russie et donc c'est pour
le tir de manière assez brève en fait
les rues son problème regardez les les
ukrainiens votaient des provinciaux ont
cédé un peu déboussolé du coup quelques
on se trompe comme ça on le paye cher à
la fin parce que parce qu'on sous estime
son adversaire les russes ont eu
beaucoup de pertes de pertes matérielles
humaines mais n'est pour la première
fois hier peskov qui est le porte parole
du kremlin il n'a pas donné de chiffres
mais il ya il a reconnu qu'il y avait
des pertes très importantes
c'est la première fois alors combien y'a
de pertes
entre les chiffres ukrainiens les
chiffres russes et chiffres américains
savary mais ce qui est très clair c'est
qu'on parle de plus de dix mille morts
je vois dans le rang dans le figaro ce
matin pour vous donner une idée sur les
chiffres c'est un site spécialiste du
décompte des matériels détruits orix
blog 74 aéronefs perdu par les russes
2573 véhicules dont 450 chars c'est pas
rien il utiliserait deux vieux char oui
alors ils ont tué des gens qui tout ce
qu'ils avaient donc à la fois des
déchets anciens des chars un peu plus un
peu plus nouveau on a fait un très bon
papier que je vous conseille sur le char
de bataille et ils obsolète et la
réponse c'est parce qu'il est trop lourd
non enfin c'est un vieux débat déjà pour
ma première mondiale y avait déjà des
généraux qui disait le char est obsolète
a gracié
non parce qu'il ya c'est que les russes
ont fait preuve dans leurs manoeuvres
d'une
enfin c'était assez archaïque c'est à
dire qu'il y avait c'était parce qu'on
appelle des manoeuvres interarmes
coordonnées ou les
les blindés les chars avance de
conserves protégés sur leur flanc avec
de l'infanterie avec des moyens de
reconnaissance aujourd'hui des drones
des moyens de anti aériens etc et donc
du coup on voyait des colonnes de chars
qu'avancer en ligne droite comme ça
comme si paradaient sur la place rouge
donc forcément celles ci sont fait taper
par les ukrainiens qui était la même en
embuscade avec les notamment les les
missiles portatifs javelot et autres
anti xa
qui taper dans le tas et et voilà mais
c'est plus un problème de de tactique de
de manoeuvre de deux commandements que
les chars chez as been ou que sais-je on
a dit qu'on parlait du sud du sud de
l'ukraine il y avait un objectif un
grand objectif le fameux port d'odessa
l'ultra stratégique port d'odessa il
faut passer par cette ville de nicolay f
qui est ici pour pouvoir y accéder par
ce qu'il est un fleuve ici le bouge
méridionale il ya un pont pour traverser
pour aller vers odessa il est dans
mikolaj f mais les russes n'ont pas
réussi à prendre cette ville et il
recule odessa c'est oublier pour
l'instant c'est très loin en anglais le
mobilier c'est impossible et ce qui
prouve quand même que les les objectifs
russes n'ont pas athènes n'ont pas été
atteints départ ils ont avancé à carson
disons-le elle c'était la plus grande
ville que les russes âgés toujours le
cas et là il se fortifie je pense que
les ukrainiens tout cas à court terme ne
vont pas essayer de reprendre personnes
ce qu'on a cru ya quelques semaines à
vous il ya eu des contre attaques
peut-être que je me trompe pas mais à
voir mais pour l'instant c'est plutôt
une stabilisation la ligne de front à
cet endroit là mais sous les russes au
départ non respect personnes avaient
quasiment encerclée nikolaïev et ensuite
entre nikolaïev et au dessin n'y a que
100 km à vol d'oiseau c'est pas grand
chose et je pense que les russes
pensaient atteindre dessin assez
rapidement la preuve en est c'est qu'il
y avait des navires de débarquement kto
au large de dessin oui on avait en avait
vu certaines des images au loin que les
américains regarder ça et disaient oui
j'allais probablement y avoir un
débarquement mais peut pas y avoir de
débarquement sans appui sur terre
absolument les russes n'ont pas les
moyens notamment et non pas les bateaux
s'ils avaient eu les mistral français
peut-être qu'ils auraient pu bon
d'accord la lie ils peuvent pas et donc
on savait qu'il fallait que ça avance de
concert une opération amphibie d'un côté
une opération qui reste de l'autre
aujourd'hui c'est impossible parce que
parce que les russes l'éventualité de
continuer à avancer vers l'ouest
à court terme c'est impossible
néanmoins le point que je voudrais
souligner c'est que donc à la dette du
tour du 9 mai 9 mais ça veut pas dire
que la guerre va s'arrêter dans un mois
il ya des responsables américains qui
ont prévenu que la guerre pourrait durer
des années si on serait dans un scénario
à la
syrien
et donc si vous voulez si les russes
c'est vraiment au conditionnel si les
russes arrivent à
apprendre le nom base donc ils gagnent
la bataille décisive du nom masse où
tout devrait se concentrer dans les deux
semaines on va dire que c'est le ce que
je vois je vois une question la sueur
sur le figaro il dit vrai pensez vous
que les russes vont bientôt se révolter
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression que les
rues sont en train de reculer en train
de perdre mais pas tout à fait et on
parle pas forcément de révolte qui ont
compétence de venir y livrer une belle
vie dounia et et c'est le gars vous
d'une conférence du figaro il il en a
très bien très bien parler le l'opinion
russe aujourd'hui
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu penser un
moment en occident se disait c'est une
folie de lanières poutine et et
il n'aura pas le soutien du peuple et
c'est peut-être qu'il n'avait pas au
départ d'ailleurs mais en revanche
aujourd'hui c'est un effet assez
classique de la guerre c'est l'effet
drapeaux et aujourd'hui il est probable
que les russes ont quand même soudé
jusqu'à présent autour de lédignan
poutine on avait fait un papier notre
correspondant à moscou il ya un institut
de sondage
en russie qui est plutôt jugé sérieux il
est indépendant d'ailleurs y est classé
comme agent de l'étranger par moscou
levada et qui a quand même montré que la
cote de popularité de vanières poutine
avait bondi à 81 3% il ya beaucoup de
chefs d'état occidentaux qui aimerait
bien avoir une telle moyenne haute mer
et par ailleurs il ya à peu près je
crois 78 % des russes qui sont
favorables à l'opération militaire
spéciale donc pour l'instant ça ne l
implosion russe
nenê n'est pas tellement
d'actualité donc on se place dans une
potentialité ça c'est un truc qui peut
bien comprendre d'une guerre longue très
longue et si les russes gagnent la
bataille du nom basse on peut imaginer
un acte iii
ou là se posera la question
des bords de la mer noire alors
justement mais on n'en est pas du tout
là aujourd'hui justement ça c'est
l'amant la prochaine question puisque si
on y revient au but 12 ans d'une guerre
qui risque de s'éterniser
on va négocier évidemment où en sont les
négociations
la russie a été exclu hier du conseil du
3 mars est surtout symbolique qu'est ce
que ça change vraiment ils peuvent pas
être exclue définitivement parce que la
russie est membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu on a l'impression
que la russie en fait tient les rênes
finalement et en tout cas ne peut pas se
laisser faire et l'onu est un peu un peu
démunis parce qu'il ya deux points qui
sont essentiels déjà les négociations
est actuellement sont complètement
bloqués pour une raison très simple
c'est que avec l'ondé de choc de boudhha
et la situation militaire qui bouge de
nouveau
le ya aucun point d'équilibré ses volets
pour négocier ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est qu'elle
plusieurs votes à l'assemblée générale
de l'onu
qui d'ailleurs quand on regarde un peu
rapidement on a l'impression que les
russes sont isolés du monde une première
résolution qui avait d'ailleurs pas
condamné elle avait déploré
l'invasion russe de l'ukraine il y avait
trois quarts des états qui avaient voté
pour ou contre la russie on se dit oh là
là aussi est complètement isolé en
réalité quand on regarde le quart des
états qui se sont abstenus ou ont voté
contre ça représente la moitié de la
population mondiale parce qu'elle la
chine notamment ce qu'il ya la chine
parce que y'a l'inde parce qu'il ya
l'iran parce qu'il ya l'irak parce
qu'ils meurent en partie de l'afrique
donc les choses sont un peu différentes
même chose hier au vote du conseil de
ses votes de l'assemblée générale
concernant le conseil des droits de
l'homme la russie a été exclu certes le
vote a été emporté néanmoins quand on
regarde on retrouve pareil une planète
qui est divisé en 93 états membres ont
soutenu cette mesure 24 autres l'ont
rejeté oui notamment la chine l'iran la
syrie la biesme réussi le mali las il
entrave les l'algérie l'inde le brésil
ça fait du monde et puis surtout il ya
les pays qui se sont abstenus et nous
qu'on fait quand on regarde le ratio il
est encore plus faible que pour la
résolution du 2 mars et donc si vous
laissez politiquement vladimir poutine
n'est pas isolé il est coupé l'occident
indéniablement mais n'est pas isolé ce
qui n'est pas forcément une bonne chose
pour la russie ce que me disait jean
louis nesti dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure ils disaient mais il ne réussit
coupé de l'occident est une absurdité
historique et vladimir poutine le paiera
un jour parce que la russie n'est pas
une puissance asiatique il me racontait
que les chinois considéré il regarde et
vladivostok donc sur la façade pacifique
comme une ville européenne n'arrive pas
avant ça comme une ville asiatique donc
ce le grand virage à l'aise de la russie
à terme pose plein de questions première
chose quand on regarde aussi la carte
des sanctions on se rend compte que la
carte des sanctions dans le monde elle
correspond trait pour trait au bloc
occidental ni plus ni moins de la guerre
froide globalement c'est dire que c'est
l'europe l'amérique du nord - le mexique
la corée du sud déjà
ils seraient les effets spéciaux voilà
nos vérifiera c'est le bloc occidental
en gros donc parler d'isolde isolement
complet de la russie c'est faut donc ça
c'est très important de l'avoir à
l'esprit quand on pense aux négociations
alexis on arrive au bout de ce live mais
quand même j'ai des questions encore une
on en a parlé un petit peu mais on va on
va répéter mon avis le but des russes
n'est-il pas de contrôler tous les accès
à la mer on a expliqué c'est très
compliqué et c'est quasiment abandonnée
notamment du côté de ça ça peut faire
une très bonne conclusion c'est de dire
que c'est un objectif de guerre possible
mais que de rappeler que les buts de
guerre devait dans la tête de la
nicotine il ya ça d'un côté mais de
l'autre les objectifs qui émerge de la
guerre et qui émerge du rapport de
forces militaires sur le terrain et que
ça c'est à la fin c'est la guerre
elle-même qui en décidera et donc pour
l'instant c'est trop tôt pour le dire ça
va dépendre première étape quel sera le
sort du nom basse qui va gagner la
bataille décisive du dombass et à partir
de cet acte 2 le nom basse et bien on
verra s'il ya ou non un acte iii une
question quand on compose souvent est-ce
que si vladimir poutine réussi à prendre
le dombass il pourra s'en contenter et
aura une négociation possible en dix ans
j'arrête la guerre mais le dombass a
écrit mais maintenant c'est à moi et
sinon on continue c'est un scénario tout
à fait possible encore une fois comme il
n'a pas défini de manière très précise
ses buts de guerre c'est très facile
pour vous dire pour lui de dire à la fin
mais voilà les objectifs seront trompés
puisqu'ils n'ont pas été définis
initialement voulons c'est une
possibilité je voudrais terminer avec ce
qui se passe à bord awdian cas c'est
bien ça on a entendu et je vous montre
sur sur cette carte on est au nord ouest
de kiev on a vu la semaine dernière des
images des massacres de butch à dire pin
ce matin le vau l'eau des mares salines
ski le président ukrainien dit que c'est
pire à borodianka est ce qu'on sait ce
qui s'y passe et est-ce qu'on est dans
le même scénario qu'à boudchar pin
franchement j'ai pas d'informations
précises et il faut le rappeler du début
de la guerre c'est très compliqué de
de confirmer donc j'ai pas
d'informations précises
c'est probablement de même nature que
bout de chasse c'est à dire qu'encore
une fois c'est ce que je vous disais en
préambule crimes de guerre oui crimes de
guerre extrêmement grave oui et même
potentiellement crimes crimes contre
l'humanité et génocide
ashton merci d'avoir été avec moi alexis
on a fait un point on a essayé de
résumer la situation ça a beaucoup bougé
ces dernières semaines par rapport à ces
derniers jours même par rapport aux
dernières semaines où c'était plus
verrouillés il ya du vrai changement et
donc on a compris que la guerre se
concentrerait maintenant sur le dombass
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
vite sur le figaro l'âge